I think this is totally suited to IMAX  there's so much going on in every inch  of the screen there's so much action  there's so much to tell an IMAX is the  perfect place to see it because it will  do ultimate justice to say goodbye to  the Kingsmen a bit of a save the world  situation here  I think the vivid kind of colors that  Matthew has created for this world is  gonna work superb some of the kind of  gags and how vulgar and like they are  the second one is even more bonkers more  brilliant more wild more rude smooth  shocking yeah anyone was an actual spy  in the movie well I think it would  probably be about that Halle Berry Colin  Firth 100% oh good question  Halle Berry Channing I'm gonna go your  head about that it's probably Colin they  all think I work for the CIA  [Applause]  this movie is larger than life and that  experience will just make it even larger  than that so on an IMAX screen will blow  your mind  I think I'll really enjoy it on the big  screen don't  you